hello everyone my name is shahzad
nevawala
and i am the director of speech
recognition for alexa
my team consists of scientists and
engineers who are responsible for
developing the technologies to help
alexa
hear the customer name speech
recognition
language identification speaker
identification
and parallel linguistics and this is
worldwide
i would like to start by first thanking
the distinguished organizing committee
for giving me the opportunity to speak
with you
about alexa
today i hope to provide you with a
behind-the-scenes look
into the technical complexities as well
as the science
that goes into building and running
alexa so with that let's jump right in
we will first spend a few minutes
talking about the origin story of alexa
followed by an architectural overview
from there
we will focus on a small selection of
speech science related topics
that are instrumental for alexa i will
be focusing mainly on asr
and related technologies but will
provide a broad brush
for the various other components in the
system as well
we will talk a little bit about more
natural interactions
enable via paralinguistics and speaker
recognition
dive into edge processing and then wrap
up
with a look to the future
so how did alexa come to be
inspired by the computer on star trek a
team of amazon scientists and engineers
set out to build a computer in the cloud
that could be completely controlled by
voice
this voice experience could then be
built into everything
and be available everywhere
as amazon started to build out its
speech team
we also consulted with several experts
in academia
the project itself was of course secret
at the time
so no real details were an offer however
what we heard
over and over again was
whatever you do don't work on far field
far field of course was the key enabling
technology
and the core reason for alexa's success
these efforts led to the launch of the
first echo device
in november 2014 and with it the
creation
of the smart speaker category at launch
we had 13 skills from one developer
namely amazon one device and one
language
specifically us english
today we have a device for nearly every
situation
with and without screens and even on the
go
for example echo auto echo buds and echo
loop
and these are just amazon devices there
are more than a hundred thousand
alexa enabled devices in the market
with availability in 15 locales
now imagine a world where more than 100
million devices are all connected to
alexa
imagine thousands or tens of thousands
of utterances being spoken to alexa
every second billions per month
then imagine a system that has to
process all these requests
in real time with near instant responses
but it is even more challenging than
that
consider that each of these billions of
utterances
are split into 10 millisecond chunks
such that each second of speech now
consists of
100 frames each of these frames
must be scored through a compute
intensive
asr deep neural network scale of the
problem
becomes even more clear
let's look at a peak scenario imagine a
scene christmas morning
millions of alexa devices that were
bought as gifts
all light up together between 7 am and
noon local time
in each locale imagine a rolling window
where these millions of devices come
online together all for the first time
we must delight our customers especially
on christmas day
now imagine other holiday celebrations
across the world where this scenario
is repeated
each one of these utterances must run
asr speaker id language id
whisper natural language understanding
entity recognition domain routing skill
execution text to speech etc
all within a minimal response window
imagine also the system has to be up
seven by twenty four with a hundred
percent availability
for example if asr were to go down what
would happen
well alexa is a speech forward assistant
if asr were to go down all over alexa
would be down
which simply cannot happen so what does
it take
to build a system like that what does a
system like this look like
let's take a bit of a closer look first
let's take a look at the high level
workflow of alexa
there are basically four stages the
customer invokes alexa and starts
speaking to it
alexa is listening it then processes the
request
and it responds seems pretty simple
right
in reality each of these components
employ
millions of lines of code hundreds of
subsystems
and multiple machine learning models
each
a simple utterance like a weather query
alexa how's the weather in shanghai
today must be properly converted
to text via call to asr next
natural language understanding must get
the intent right
whether and entity recognition must
resolve the slot
shanghai it must get routed to the right
skill
in this case weather the weather skill
must retrieve the weather forecast
and provide the texture response
tts must then render this response in
alexa's natural voice
and all of this must happen in a flash
let's dive a little deeper into asr
itself
once a customer activates a device via
the wakeboard
audio is streamed to the cloud arriving
at the network gateway
an audio distribution framework then
routes the audio
to the services that need it including
asr
language id speaker id whisper
etc all these functions
must run in parallel otherwise latency
would be too high
but of course there are thousands of
simultaneous requests
hitting the system as a result
we must have a multi-fleet system with
thousands of aws hosts
spread across multiple regions fully
redundant availability zones
must be present for each service to
ensure
that the system is always available
this all must be streaming so we cannot
leverage bi-directional models or any
other such offline constructs
there's also no frame look ahead so as
to minimize latency
each utterance is on the average of
three to five seconds in length
and each one gets split into 10
millisecond frames
the service itself is bi-directional so
that when the end point
determines the end of our trends the
audio stream can be terminated
immediately
now let's take a look at some of the
science that is behind alexa
at amazon we are always customer
obsessed it is part of our ethos
we start with the customer and work
backwards from them
alexa must therefore work just as well
for all of our customers worldwide
this means that asr models have to adapt
to not only different languages
but different dialects vernacular
trending topics
accents native and non-native speakers
and multilingual speakers in addition
this is a touchless device
there are no correction capabilities
there is no backspace
or feedback possible in that single
utterance
we either get it right or we get it
wrong
and under all these constraints we must
provide the same great performance for
all
what kind of science and innovation does
that require
of course many of you know about or
experts in core language technologies
like asr
natural language understanding and tts
but putting them together in a system
of this scale and generalization is a
very big challenge
customers should not have to adapt the
way they speak
to match our capabilities they should be
able to interact with alexa in a way
that is natural to them
let's take a look now at some of the
challenges and the solutions
have you noticed that alexa can focus on
the person speaking
even in the presence of background
speech on media noise
how does this attention and filtering
work
typically asr is trained on the speed
segments only
however there is additional context
available
as related to the speaker channel
and environment that can be used to
enhance performance
this context is typically untranscribed
and must be learned implicitly
to use untranscribed audio context
we actually encode the entire stream
but compute loss only on the transcribed
segment
however you buy back propagate over the
full utterance
this allows the system to implicitly
adapt to the speaker
and the environment
this allows asr to focus on the speaker
that invoked alexa
the accuracy improvements are
particularly pronounced
in the presence of background or
multimedia speech inference interference
as can be seen in the table below
alexa must also be highly performant
regardless of noise
device type accents and dialects
semi-supervised learning is particularly
effective in helping to overcome these
challenges
with ssl we use a smaller amount of
label data
to train a teacher model which is then
used to label a much
larger store of unannotated data
we then use both data sets to train a
leaner more efficient student model
let's get into some of the details of
this
a teacher acoustic model which is a
powerful bi-directional lstm
but is not suited for streaming
applications it's for strain on labor
data
this teacher model provides a 25 water
rate improvement over the streaming
model
and is therefore well suited for the
task
labels for a large quantity of
previously unlabeled data
are then machine generated using the
teacher model
you will notice in the diagram both
pooled and locale based data
we will discuss these in more detail in
our next slide
for ctc ssl training machine labels are
generated by
first post-processing the teacher's
posteriors obtained by forward pass
the label sequence is obtained by taking
the arg max
over the teacher posteriors and then
removing consecutive repetitions
a student am which is a unidirectional
lstm
and suited for streaming applications is
then trained on both
labeled and unlabeled data this is a
much faster approach than running a full
decoding
especially when data volumes are very
large
next we combine ssl learning with
transfer learning which proves to be
extremely powerful
in this approach we poor transcribed and
untranscribed data from multiple
languages
to enhance a single language in this
example we show variants of
english but it can be effectively
applied to a mix of different languages
as well
the diagram on the top shows a
multi-dialect acoustic morning
acoustic modeling training pipeline
based on label data only
it consists of three stages the pool ctc
label data
from the four variants is first used to
train an overall english model
then a look how specific ctc training is
applied
using only the data from the target
locale to fine-tune the model
this is then followed by locale specific
discriminative training
the diagram at the bottom represents a
multi-dialect acoustic model pipeline
based on both labeled and unlabeled data
in this we combine 75 000 hours of label
data
with more than one million hours of
unlabeled
multi-dialect english data and leverage
it to improve
all three stages of acoustic model
training
the poor ctc ssl the locale specific ctc
ssl
and the locale specific discriminative
training
the ssl data to be labeled can be made a
lot more effective
by careful automated selection based on
confidence filters and speaker and
domain diversity
this table shows us the accuracy
improvements from the techniques we just
discussed
the full tech combination of all
techniques resulted
in a 22 to 29 improvement in overall
word error rate
over the baseline model
let's talk a little bit about rescoring
generalized neural language language
rescoring models
are very effective for re-ranking the
output of the first pass esr system
however a general model does not take
full advantage of the context that is
available
for instance is the domain or topic of
the utterance related to
shopping navigation or music
with domain aware we scoring we use an
intent classifier
to guess the domain of the utterance we
can then
use domain specialized re-rankers to
extract the best possible result
even though the precision and recall of
the classification
exceeds 90 percent these specialized
models must still be robust to
classification errors
as you can see we can get significant
word error rate improvement
over just a generalized risk order
the general rescorer also just uses the
lattice
in order to re-rank
however adding attention to audio
provides additional context for
discriminating between alternate
hypotheses
leading to a 7.7 percent improvement
in word error rate
these language models are also hard to
adapt
personalization of entities like contact
names or playlists are essential to
correct recognition
new catalog entries for songs and movies
are equally challenging
these also have to scale across millions
of users
and must support very frequent updates
the answer lies in composite models
the set of entities that a user may
reference is constantly growing
or are dependent on the user and the
application
for example for a communications
application we need to pull names from
the list of contacts
for many other scenarios we need global
catalogues
for example geographical locations
or an app may provide the entity list
for its own purposes such as the
characters of a tv show
or rooms in a home we want the lm
the language model to access these lists
of entity names
but how do we know when to invoke them
the standard solution is to build
language models in terms of class labels
such as location the language model
predicts the class
then we have a separate model to predict
the possible class members
given the type of class the membership
models
can be context dependent or personalized
however to train class-based models we
need those classes or entity types
annotated in our data annotating
significant amounts of data is very
expensive
and adding new classes would require
re-labeling all data
and in the case of third-party
applications where each application can
have its own entity types it's not very
clear
how to scale the labeling process
also note that in this example the
location in the sentence is
my hometown while the entity model only
contains hometown
the annotation process itself can
introduce discrepancies
can we do without these animations it
turns out that we can
the basic idea is to let a neural model
learn the context
under which different classes become
good predictors of
words we have a set of component models
that can generate
words but some generate only specific
entities
let's take a communications interaction
as an example
alexa called shazad mevala
we want to leverage the user's
personalized contact list
to guide and personalize the second pass
url and rescoring
we combine the components predictions
using an attention mechanism
but we also have to learn which models
are good at generating particular
portions of an input query
for example a personalized contact list
slot
is not really good at generating words
from the carrier phrase in our example
alexa call but are good at generating
slot words
shazad nivawala
the model learns which component model
should be activated
at particular positions of a query and
in addition which models are good at
predicting
next word and position based on the
context
we use a context encoder to make a fixed
size
representation from the sequence of
previous words
this is the query in the attention
mechanism
but also the input to guide the
activation component
to help with the learning as to which
model should be activated at any
position
this is matched against the learnable
embeddings
that represent each component model
these serve as the key
in the attention mechanism
the attention mechanism computes the
weighting of the different
component predictions according to the
match
between the queries and the keys
so far this is just context dependent
interpolation of models
but some components can generate only
parts of a sentence
they need to be told when to start
generating their content
we use a novel mechanism we call
activation
which resets the state of a component to
tell it to start generating its content
activation is also computed by matching
context queries against component keys
but each component decides independently
and probably probabilistically when to
activate
for training the activation model we use
reinforcement learning
there is no need for label data because
bad propagating the errors allows the
model to learn
when to call on each component based on
context
and what the component predicts
we applied the neural composition model
to combine a default language model with
personalized contact lists for
communication tasks
on in-domain utterances perplexity was
cut in half
and recognition improved by 10 relative
no degradation was found on out of
domain data so the model
learned not to pay attention to the
contact name component in those cases
even without training unlabeled data
for far field applications interactions
are usually explicitly triggered via
invoking the wake word
but termination must be computed by
automatically
inferring when a user is done speaking
end to early and you may cut off the
speaker
wait too long and you add latency or
risk
introducing unintended insertions the
system must learn to respond
instantly at the end of a spoken query
but also be patient if the user
hesitates
or pauses during speech
end pointing uses no explicit feature
extraction
we instead fuse multiple signals
including
acoustic embeddings for example silence
one best hypothesis from the asr decoder
as well as expected pauses based on the
linguistic position
within the sentence
we also want alexa to effectively use
features
beyond just speech recognition in order
to enhance the
overall customer experience whisper
is a great example when you whisper to
alexa
she will whisper back that is a magical
experience for customers
for example when you set alarms late in
the evening
while your family is sleeping or when
you're checking calendar weather or
traffic
early each morning while others are
still asleep
the whisper feature allows alexa to
understand that this is a quiet
environment
and behave like humans would do
whisper speech is mainly characterized
as unvoiced speech
studies of spectrograms have suggested
that whisper speech
overall has less energy at lower
frequency bands compared to normal
speech
we came up with a system that consists
of an lstm neural network
trained and evaluated on recordings of
human interactions
with voice controlled far-field devices
in whisper
and normal modes but it's not just about
the science on the detection side that
makes this feature magical
we were also able to create a
comfortable whispering voice
from text to speech and response the
response
in kind is what makes the experience
magical
if you allow alexa to recognize your
voice
she can greet you by name and
personalize your experience for example
music playlists
shopping carts etc speaker enrollment
commences with the user speaking four
short phrases
we designed these phrases not just to be
simple and topical
but also to provide the greatest
phonetic coverage
allowing us to deliver the best
recognition accuracy
a lexus speaker id system uses a
combination of two different model types
the text dependent model knows what
you're saying ahead of time
with alexa most utterances start with
the wake word
so it matches the way you said alexa now
with the way you said alexa before then
there's a text
independent model which matches your
voice regardless of what you're saying
moving both these systems to full neural
and combining them
has given us an order of magnitude
improvement in speaker id accuracy
instead of fusing the decision scores of
multiple models
for example a straight average we fuse
the embeddings
generated by the component models which
are all neural
this allows us to let the model learn to
estimate
any missing embeddings from the ones
that are present
for example if the utterance did not
start with the wake word
this neural fusion method gave up to a
15
relative reduction in overall false
reject rate
and when one of the inputs is missing
the false reject reduction
was up to 53
now let's switch topics and talk a
little bit about edge processing or
processing on the device itself
when you're processing on the cloud you
have an unlimited amount
of computation power to run the powerful
machine learning algorithms that are
required
for voice assistance now imagine you
want to fit
this functionality and squeeze it into
a device no bigger than a tin can
you have almost no memory megabytes
instead of gigabytes
a fraction of the compute and no
dedicated
system resources
how does one accomplish something like
that
in the latest amazon devices we've
incorporated our new az-1 neural edge
processor
which is a neural network accelerator
that allows us
to run these sophisticated ml algorithms
efficiently and quickly right on the
device
this neural processor will allow us to
move all audio processing
to the device current echo devices
listen for the wake word on the device
and once detected they stream
audio to the cloud for all for the
processing
these new devices give us the capability
to execute
asr speaker id and whisper on the device
itself
such that only a textual representation
needs to be sent to the cloud
this means faster response times
especially
on narrowband with connections
let's now review for a minute how
classic hybrid asr architectures work
a hybrid esr system is comprised of
multiple components
a signal processing front end takes raw
audio frames as input
and produces a stream of feature vectors
that serve as inputs
to the acoustic model the acoustic model
then produces phoneme probabilities
for each given frame the decoder then
combines
the phoneme predictions with the
pronunciation lexicon
as well as the engram-based language
model
to execute a large search over all
possible combinations of words
to find the most likely sequence
these multiple components when packaged
together especially when inclusive
of the large language model results in
an extremely large
overall asr model size
these components are replaced when
moving to an end-to-end architecture
the technology we adopted and extended
for all neural asr
is commonly referred to as rnn
transducer
or rnnt it consists of an encoder
network that transforms the audio
signals
into a new frame by frame representation
over time
a prediction network that encodes the
respectively current
word sequence and a network that brings
both pieces of
information together to yield
probabilities for all potential next
words
or word pieces with an end to end model
you no longer have the overhead of the
various separate components
or those giant search trees instead you
now have a full neural representation
which by itself reduces the size of the
model
to 1 100 the original size
various quantization techniques minimize
the memory and compute footprint even
further
without losing any accuracy these models
can then be deployed on a devices
and executed using our amazon euro
processor
but what about even smaller devices like
wearables
or automotive applications some of these
may not even have
internet connectivity
one of the techniques is obviously model
compression and quantization
quantization helps to reduce model size
computation
and latency the main problem is that
post training quantization
leads to severe performance degradation
to achieve the best performance on
device
we need to incorporate the hardware
architecture into the model training
itself
with this solution we were able to
reduce the model size
by 4x without degrading the performance
of a speech recognition model
furthermore this solution requires
minimal overhead for memory and
computation
which makes it well suited for models
with large number of parameters
such as speech recognition or even text
to speech
another approach to reduce footprint and
latency are signaled intent models
the conventional approach to spoken
language understanding
uses two different components to
sequentially process
a spoken entrance the asr model first
converts the customer audio to a text
transcription followed by the natural
language understanding model that
converts this
transcription to a semantic
interpretation
this approach has worked well so far
especially with the adoption of neural
technologies for both esr and nlu models
however this modular design has a few
drawbacks
the component models are trained
independently with separate objectives
can be word error rate for asr and cross
entropy for nlu the errors made by the
asr model
can lead to an incorrect nlu model
prediction
since these errors are absent from the
nlu training data
finally this design assigns equal
importance to each word
in the three examples shown here the
word error rate for each utterance is 25
however missing a key word from the
utterance will lead to a non-recoverable
nlu error the word error metric does not
differentiate this effect
when looking at the final model
performance
an approach to address this problem is
to employ models that can predict the
spoken
language understanding output directly
from speech
these end-to-end slu models are trained
on a single optimization objective
that is to correctly predict the
utterance interpretation
these models are robust to component
specific errors
moreover they are resource and latency
efficient
instead of having multiple models to get
the final interpretation
we now have a single model often with
fewer total number of parameters that
can predict the final interpretation
this finally leads to smaller sizes and
overall less computational overhead
looking a bit to the future virtual
assistants are still
early in their revolution they work
really well for command and control type
interactions
controlling smart home devices answering
questions
playing music where we really want to
get though
are true conversational assistants
alexa's natural turn-taking feature
which we plan to launch
next year will let customers interact
with alexa more naturally
without the need to repeat the wake word
the features
ai will be able to recognize when users
have finished speaking
when the speech is directed at the
device and when it is not
and whether or not a reply is expected
natural tone taking uses acoustic cues
to distinguish device directed and noise
non-device directed speech
it adds other cues such as visual
information from devices with cameras
on device algorithms processes process
images
and audio infer from the speaker's body
position where they're
likely to be addressing alexa and infer
from the audio whether it is directed to
the device
or to someone else
we still have many challenges to solve
self-correction capabilities
code switching interpreting
paralinguistic cues from customers
and true high fidelity long-form
conversational asr
are just some examples
though it has evolved over several
decades thanks to steady progress
in academic government and industry
research
speech technology has seen rapid
progress over the last few years
this is thanks mainly to deep learning
algorithms
as well as the low-cost compute hardware
necessary to support them
as we also saw in this presentation
building a virtual assistant
requires the orchestration of several
critical
sub tasks like wake word detection
endpointing asr nw tts etc
and while we have made great progress it
is still day one
and a great time to be a speech
researcher
thank you very much for your time and
attention i will now be happy to answer
any questions that you may have